Qué implicaciones tiene el haber
detectado estas partículas enriquecidas
cerca del 90% y podría realmente
tratarse de una fluctuación no
intencional como Está alegando Irán
qué tal Valentina Buenas tardes bueno
podría técnicamente efectivamente
tratarse de una fluctuación pero dada
las las digamos la poca transparencia
que Irán está mostrando últimamente en
sus operaciones de enriquecimiento es
importante que la audiencia entienda que
enriquecimiento significa aumentar la
proporción del isótopo 235 del uranio
que es el isótopo fionable es decir el
necesario para hacer
bombas y otras digamos también
y yo incisión también con fines
pacíficos pero en este caso bombas
en el uranio es decir el uranio no en el
uranio tal cual está en la en la
naturaleza en la cantidad del porcentaje
del isótopos 35 es muy baja hay que
aumentarla de manera artificial eso se
llama enriquecimiento sí es aumentar el
isótopos 35 respecto de su composición
original Entonces si si se llega a
niveles de enriquecimiento el 20% uno
suponer que el objetivo de ese
enriquecimiento es con fines pacíficos
centrales nucleares usos médicos
etcétera enriquecer a más a un
porcentaje mayor ya levanta sospechas
aunque no sea el 80% aunque sea el 60%
quieran estar reconociendo es decir es
difícil pensar que un país enriquece al
60% con fines pacíficos sí 60% no es
posible todavía con requisimiento del
por ciento no es posible lograr un
aparato destructivo de manera eficiente
pero si llegaron al 60% no debería
pensar que quieren digamos ir más
adelante o que tiene un objetivo que no
es Pacífico entonces efectivamente
podría ser que en ese proceso
enriquecimiento sin quererlo digámoslo
así hayan logrado en algún en algún
elemento porcentaje del 80% pero en un
contexto político bueno como el iraní
genera sospechas bueno en términos de
reservas el Hoya aseguró que Irán Tiene
18 veces el nivel autorizado por el
pacto de 2015 pero estamos hablando de
un momento de estancamiento de los
diálogos tras el retiro de Estados
Unidos y pues cómo se le exige a esta
nación que cumpla con los términos de un
acuerdo que en este momento está en el
Limbo
bueno exactamente como tú lo dices el
acuerdo está suspendido el acuerdo no
está en vigencia y por lo tanto Irán
efectivamente no está cumpliendo con el
acuerdo pero es un acuerdo que no está
en vigencia y ahí hay alguna
responsabilidad también del gobierno
anterior de los Estados Unidos que
queriendo endurecer se retira del
acuerdo Entonces eso le abrió a mi
juicio muy subjetivo Y opinable por
supuesto pero a mi juicio Estados Unidos
comete un error ahí error que está
tratando de enmendar la actual
administración porque al abrirse del
acuerdo los Estados Unidos le abrieron
la puerta a Irán para que Irán se fuera
del acuerdo Entonces hoy Irán
efectivamente está con niveles digamos
con cantidad de uranio enriquecido muy
superior a lo que permite el acuerdo
Irán lo reconoce O al menos no lo niega
pero el acuerdo no está en vigencia y
hoy Bueno irán a da la sensación de que
se está poniendo mucho más exigente para
volver al acuerdo exigente el sentido de
pedir más cosas en contrapartida que las
que pedían